mein name ist marie agnes strack
zimmermann ich bin eine freie demokraten
kandidiere für die fdp im wahlkreis 106
das ist der nördliche wahlkreis der
landeshauptstadt düsseldorf die hochburg
der fdp liegt am rhein im
bundestagswahlkreis düsseldorf 1 hat die
partei vor vier jahren 19 7 prozent der
zweitstimmen erhalten
bei den erststimmen gingen 12,8 prozent
an marie agnes strack zimmermann
was macht düsseldorf aus
also düsseldorf ist ja nach dem krieg
das ist ja eine spannende geschichte und
das prägt die stadt auch sehr ist ja von
den engländer zur landeshauptstadt
gekürt wurden was die kölner und ich
meine das jetzt nicht augenzwinkern bis
heute nicht überwunden haben oder
verwandten haben weil köln historisch
gesehen natürlich die viel bedeutendere
stadt ist das läuft es nach dem krieg
dadurch dass das ruhegebiet den boden
nicht um sonst der schreibtisch des
ruhrgebiets genannt also alle großen
firmen die im ruhrgebiet im kohlebergbau
waren stahl kohle hatten hier ihr büro
so dass hier schon sehr früh hoch
versteuert wurde und düsseldorf konnte
dadurch relativ früh ja schon deutlich
investieren und ich glaube was bei
düsseldorf auch einfach ein wieso
neudeutsch als asset ist dass die stadt
eigentlich gar nicht groß ist und
wirklich kontakt zu fuß alles zu
erreichen ist was eine stadt spannend
macht also partyleben reinkultur
können sie eigentlich wenn sie gute
schuhe anhaben in zwei stunden alles zu
fuß machen
wie ticken die düsseldorfer wenn sie mit
mir über den markt gehen da haben sie
das ist sehr einig fröhlich laut
herzlich das sind die düsseldorfer und
die gibt es im karneval da gibt es im
schützenwesen in brauchtum hansel die
alle so die dann auch zu einer 80
jährigen noch sagen na junge frau wie
geht's oder ich zu einem hundertjährigen
wenn ich bürgermeister es gab ja kaum
100 jährige männer es tut mir leid was
alles frauen aber wenn es dann mal einen
gab dann war das eine große party
und wenn ich sage junger mann alles klar
dann wahrhaft er sich weckt vorfreude
das können sie nicht überall machen ich
glaube es gibt landstrich in deutschland
da würde er sagen gewesen sie eigentlich
mit mir warum war die fdp bei der
letzten wahl in düsseldorf so stark dass
hatte eindeutig was damit zu tun weil
wir hier einfach sowohl christian
lindner also strack-zimmermann also wir
beide haben hier kandidiert das war mein
wahlkreis aber lindner war durch die
aufbaujahre 13 bis 17 hier sehr sehr
präsent er wohnte hier ja noch war
fraktionsvorsitzender im land
kdh da kamen zwei zusammen das passt
eher unheimlich gut da war der junge
lindner da war die ältere
strack-zimmermann meine frau düsseldorf
also das was ich glaube ich eine sehr
gute mischung was können andere
fdp-politiker von ihnen lernen also mein
credo ist dass ich im wahlkämpfen nicht
die anderen angreifer sondern mich
bemühe
unsere stärken anzubieten also nicht
dieses der es doof und der stoff weil
das will keiner hören ich glaube dass
das in den zeiten wo leute zwar
natürlich unterschiede wissen wollen
aber eine positive botschaft wollen wir
wollen doch nicht dass ich hier
rumlaufen und schlechte laune verbreiten
sondern wir haben ein problem wir haben
eine panne die die menschen
unterschiedlich getroffen hat und den
jetzt zu sagen so die zukunft könnte so
aussehen gibt uns die chance also ein
angebot machen ich glaube dass das das
empfehle ich was ist ihr ziel bei der
wahl
ich möchte einfach gut abschneiden aber
wenn ich ihnen jetzt eine zahl sorge und
ich bin 0,1 prozent darunter da habe ich
die arschkarte gezogen